we will be talking
about a new topic today.
And that's polymers.
And we're going to
start by talking about--
what I want to do
is cover two ways
that we humans make polymers.
And the first way has to do with
something called the radical.
So that's where I want
to start our story.
And what is a radical?
Well, a radical is
a molecule that has
one or more unpaired electrons.
So one or more
unpaired electrons.
But as you can imagine, if
I've got an unpaired electron,
it's kind of like a broken bond.
It's kind of like a broken bond.
That's a radical.
And you could also
imagine that a broken bond
wants to not be broken.
So it's going to try to
find something to bond to.
That's why we've got radicals
all in us all the time.
Sometimes they're important,
but sometimes they
can cause a lot of harm.
And that's why if you
eat blueberries, then
you get these things
called antioxidants.
And antioxidants, that's
just one of many, many types
of antioxidants.
What do they do?
They go and they
give these radicals
what they need, what they're
looking for, an electron.
They give them an electron.
And they don't mind.
They don't become
radical themselves.
They just simply stop the
radical from being radical.
Now, why does this matter?
Well, we're going to see
what that means for polymers.
But let's make a radical.
So imagine-- and I'm
going to go Lewis on us,
because I want to
see the electrons.
I'm going to go Lewis.
So imagine I've got methane.
Well, methane looks like
this, nice and happy.
Oh, the octet.
But now I introduced
a chlorine atom.
So I've got now chlorine.
And chlorine is hungry.
Chlorine wants to fill
its octet by itself.
And so what does it do?
It's like, well, I'm powerful.
I'm strong.
I'm just going to
grab from methane.
It sees methane,
and it's like, OK,
you give me one
of your electrons.
How about that is a deal?
And here we go.
And it takes it in the
form of the hydrogen.
And so we got this like
this, and like this.
Oh, the chlorine
got really happy,
but look at what
happened to the methane.
It lost an electron
and a hydrogen with it,
and it has an unpaired electron.
That electron is not happy.
I mean, it just wants
to bond to something.
That's all.
You can't blame it.
Don't we all want that?
The problem is that this
really needs it badly.
And so this is called--
so what we did is
we took chlorine,
and we combined it with methane.
And we made what's
called a methyl radical.
So this is called--
that's called a free radical.
Or in this case, it's
methyl, because that's
what the chemistry is.
It's a methyl radical.
As we'll see, you can make
radicals out of lots of stuff.
Just take a hydrogen
and an electron
that have a free
unpaired electron left,
and it's a radical.
I could start with ethane and
make an ethyl radical, C2H5
with a dot.
That dot is the
unpaired electron.
And so on, and so on.
And so if you have free
radicals and they come along,
and there's some
other molecules--
it's not going to be this
one, but maybe there's
something like an antioxidant
in those blueberries.
It's going to come along.
I've got electrons
I could give you.
Here, have one.
I see how needy you are.
I see how badly you want one.
You can take one of mine.
And I'll be fine.
I'll be fine.
Or maybe we'll form
a bond with that.
Those are antioxidants.
But that's not the topic.
The topic is we're making this
new material called a polymer.
So how does that work?
Well, to understand
that, we've got
to make a radical out
of a special case.
We've got to make a radical out
of a double-bonded molecule.
So now I'm going from methane
to the double-bonded ethane.
Now, hang on.
Let me put this up here.
And in the case of a double
bond, something very important
happens.
Something very
important happens.
And the reason is that
I've got two bonds.
I've got two bonds, not one.
Well, that's what double bond--
that is what double bond means.
But I can now-- because
I've got a double bond,
I can do something
very important.
When I turn that
molecule into a radical,
something special happens.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
not going to call it chlorine.
I'm going to just call it R dot.
And because now we're making a
polymer, and this is called--
well, it's got different names.
It's called radical,
or sometimes you'll
see it as addition
polymerization.
And this is the first kind of
polymer I want to talk about.
And so I'm going--
you saw how it
worked with chlorine.
I'm just going to say, I've
got something called R.
And it's called a
radical initiator.
And I'm going to draw
the dot there, just
like I had the dot on chlorine.
This is going to be
the radical initiator.
Radical initiator.
And I'm going to now bring this
to my double-bonded molecule.
That's the key.
The key is in the double bond.
So watch what happens.
So first, here's what happens.
I've got R with its dot plus--
and again, I'm
going to go Lewis.
I'm going to have all those
electrons in the bonds spelled
out for you with dots.
So R plus C. Two pairs
of electrons in there.
Do you see that?
There's my double bond.
And here are the hydrogens.
I'm not going to
draw them every time.
Those sticks have
hydrogens on the ends.
But now watch what happens.
So now, this radical,
like the chlorine,
it sees this electron, and
it says, aha, I can take you.
I can take you.
And I will be happy
if I take this.
And this double-bonded
molecule can't really
stop it from happening.
So the radical now can bond
to the carbon over here.
It's got these two.
Those are those two
hydrogens that were there.
But now watch what happens.
Now I've got here, here, here.
And then I've got this.
And I've got this.
But now this is a
radical, because this
has an unpaired electron.
This has an unpaired electron.
And so often what we'll
do is we'll write this.
We'll often just write it.
I'm just going to rewrite it,
just because then it gets us
in the mood for what's going
to happen next as a single bond
with the two hydrogens and
the radical sitting there.
I just took this
unpaired electron
and put it out on the end there.
That's a radical again.
And I haven't broken the bond.
That's the key.
The double bond
allowed a radical
to come in, take
an electron, make
a new radical out of the whole
thing, and remain stable.
That's what the
double bond gave me.
So if I go to step
two, what happens?
If I go to step
two, well, now, I've
got this R that's sitting here.
And I've got these here.
And I've got--
I'll put them in
explicitly, and there.
Obviously, this is in a bucket
of these C2H4 molecules.
They're all over the place.
And now this is going to see--
so we're going to
do that, and this
is going to see another one.
Let's put that one in here.
Here we go.
A double bond, nice and
happy, floating along.
And this radical
version of it sees it.
And it says, nope, I
need that electron.
Thank you very much.
And so you get this.
Single bond, single bond.
And we'll just put it out here.
And so now, how many did I have?
2, 4, and here's another one.
And there it is.
And I've got another radical.
I've got another radical.
The thing stays radical
until it finds another R dot.
So this just goes
on and on and on.
This is a new radical.
New radical.
And each time it finds a
double-bonded C2H4 molecule,
it can take it, add it to the
chain, add it to the chain.
Sometimes this is called
chain polymerization,
addition polymerization,
radical polymerization.
You see it's all the same.
You see how it works,
because I'm making a chain,
and I keep on adding
the same building
block, the same molecule.
That's really important.
The same molecule, and
then et cetera, et cetera.
Well, how long is et cetera?
Well, typical polymers
go on for a long time.
We're talking a
minimum of 100 times.
100, you might be able to
draw that all the way down,
maybe down to there.
But a lot of polymers go to
100,000 or a million chain
links, a million.
That makes this class of
materials extremely unique.
And we're going to talk
about them in the next--
over the next-- well,
during this week.
What I want to do
is give you a couple
of reasons why they're
unique, and then we're
going to go into my
"Why This Matters."
What we started
with was a monomer.
In this case, we started
with ethylene or ethene,
and so here was our monomer.
And what we ended up
with is a polymer.
And in this case, it's--
oh, boy-- I'll draw it
straight like I did there.
OK, here we go.
Here we go.
This is the polymer.
But see, I don't want to
write 100,000 carbon letters
on my page.
You can you can't blame
polymer chemists for that.
And so what we do is we
have a notation, where
if this was the monomer, one.
Poly, many.
Mer, C2H4.
Then what you do is
you take the monomer
and you write it
in a special way
to show that it's
become a polymer.
And you put the monomer inside.
Oh, let's just write those
hydrogens explicitly.
Why not?
There they are.
They were there, too.
But now what you do is
you put parentheses.
And to show that it's a polymer,
this bond comes out the edge.
That shows I had this monomer.
Now, notice, this is the same
as a monomer, but a single bond.
Why?
Because that double bond, to
keep on making it radical,
I change them all
into single bonds.
Each time I made
the chain longer.
And then we put an n, because
it could repeat n times.
And that's a polymer.
So the chain bonds are
sticking out of the edges
like that of the parentheses.
Polymer chemists aren't as--
the crystallographers,
you don't want to upset.
Polymer chemists are fine.
So if you put brackets there,
yeah, they're OK with it.
It's not so bad.
Parentheses, brackets.
The main thing is those
bonds that are polymerizing,
those bonds that are
forming the chain
have to come out
of the parentheses,
and then the little n
there is how many times.
So a couple of things
we can talk about.
So polymer, monomer.
Well, one thing, a
couple of things.
So the molecular weight
is going to be high.
It's going to be
typically, and again,
thousands of grams
per mole, because it's
a mole of the molecule.
This is a molecule.
It's just a very, very
long chain molecule.
And so polymer people
and bio people,
they like using Daltons.
1 Dalton equals 1 gram per mole.
Why switch to Daltons?
I don't know!
It's just a unit thing.
So don't get confused.
Dalton is a gram per mole.
A kiloDalton is
1,000 grams per mole.
We can say like a Da.
Maybe they just
like the symbol, Da.
Or kDa for kiloDaltons.
It's just grams per
mole, thousands of grams.
But now one long chain, if
I know the molecular weight
in grams per mole,
then I kind of also
could know how long it is.
Back and forth, it's
just a molecule.
It's just that this is a
very, very big molecule.
And so sometimes you'll see
it called a macromolecule.
Macro.
It's huge!
It's a long chain.
You just think about how the
length is on the order of--
I'll spell it out-- microns.
Just think about it.
We've been talking about a
lot of different materials
in this class.
We've been talking about a lot
of different solid materials.
Perfect crystals.
Crystals with defects.
Amorphous materials.
Molecular solids.
This is another class of
solid, but you can really
start to think about why
this is so different.
Because if this thing is
100,000 or a million units long,
that strand is a very
long piece of spaghetti.
And that means that
different things can happen.
And that's one of the reasons
why polymers are so interesting
and can be so useful.
And so if you think about taking
it longer, this isn't even--
we're not even
close to how long--
this is still just a little
longer, but what I'm showing
you is something important.
If I've got spaghetti
that that's long,
you better believe
it can tangle up.
And so when you think
about one of these strands
or maybe a couple
of them, they're
going to usually,
often, not always--
you can make crystals out of
polymers, but a lot of times
they're going to tangle,
because they're just so long.
And the degree of the
length, by the way, that's
another thing, degree
of polymerization.
Ah, why was my O so big there?
I don't know.
It was a moment.
I'm feeling it with the O.
And that's the number of mer--
yeah, it's a polymer--
mer units.
And that's per polymer.
And this is average, because
as you can imagine, it's very--
I'm going out to a million.
Did I hit a million
or did I get 990,000?
Or did I get a million and 10?
You don't control
the length exactly.
And so the degree
of polymerization
is the number that
is the average.
It's the average.
It's the same as the
molecular weight.
It's an average, because the
strands have a distribution.
And we'll talk about
that more on Wednesday.
But now I just want to get
down some polymer insights.
So we got things like
molecular weight,
degree of polymerization.
Now, these are very long.
And so you can imagine that
it's kind of like glasses
when we did glasses.
These are really long chains.
You can imagine as a liquid
that might be pretty viscous.
That might be pretty viscous.
You could also imagine
that when you solidify it,
it might be pretty disordered,
or maybe crystalline.
It might have some
similarities with glass.
Again, we'll talk about
that more Wednesday.
But the one thing I
want to highlight now
is that what can happen
because it's so long
is that you can
literally get what?
You can literally get like
one polymer chain that
finds itself wanting to
form a crystal literally
like in the middle of itself.
And then it's like, OK, I can
stack and form a nice crystal,
but now I can't again.
And now, oh, look, I think I
can pack in nicely as a crystal.
And now I can't again.
And it just goes, I could--
I'm really enjoying this.
I could just keep going.
That's one polymer strand!
And it would keep going.
It literally would, because
it's like 100,000 units long.
So you can imagine
that polymers, just one
strand of a polymer can
be incredibly complicated,
because it might have some
regions that are crystalline
and some that are amorphous.
And by the way, we know
that the crystalline region
will be very different.
This is going to have the
lowest volume per mole.
So this will have-- maybe
this will be the hardest.
Maybe it will be
the most brittle.
So does it crystallize?
Does it not?
That's going to be something
that's very important.
How much of it crystallizes?
A micron, by the way, the
length is also important.
That's like visible
light, wavelength.
So optical properties will
depend on these things.
And so what you have is
this new form of matter
that we have in
the last 50 years
engineered and understood
more and more how to control.
And so we're talking about
this addition polymerization.
This list goes on and
on and on now today.
So what is this list?
Well, these are all--
I want you to notice here--
monomer.
This is the polymer name.
This is the monomer.
Here's the polymer.
They should have put
parentheses there.
We'll excuse that,
because you can
feel that those are going
outside of the parentheses
or brackets.
And then here's the use.
So what did we just do?
We just did polyethylene.
Polyethylene is right there.
That's the polymer polyethylene.
There is the monomer.
There is the polymer.
Now, notice something
about every single one
of these monomers.
There it is.
They've all got
that double bond,
that double-bonded carbon.
So when I put a
radical initiator
in a soup of those monomers,
I can form polymer chains.
And those are the
polymers you make.
And notice they all start--
these are the same
unit repeating
over and over and over again.
And notice the flexibility here.
So in polyethylene, which
is one of the simplest cases
and is the most common polymer,
these are just a few uses.
If I just take one of
those hydrogens off
of one of the two carbons--
there's polyethylene up there--
if I just take one
of the hydrogens off,
and instead I put
a benzene ring.
So now I've got this.
Oh, boy.
Did I draw that?
Yeah, it's OK.
Here's my hydrogens
coming off of the benzene.
There you go.
And there, and
there, and oh, good.
I've drawn
polystyrene, haven't I?
No, I have not!
Because you've got to come out!
That's a polymer.
Now it's a polymer.
I came out.
Well, that's pretty simple.
All I did is I just
took the polyethylene,
and I put a benzene ring there.
And I get Styrofoam if
I put air through it
as I make it processing.
Or I can make all sorts
of other things out of it.
That's polystyrene.
This is why polymers have
become such an incredibly
important and enormous
part of our lives,
because you can see if I just
change the monomer, I just
change one thing
in one molecule,
and then get a bucket of those.
I might completely change the
solid that comes out of it.
But all sorts of things
are going to change.
You can imagine that just
the way the chain folds up
on itself like that,
maybe the way the chain
comes and talks to
another chain, or maybe
a part of itself.
When I say talk and I'm talking
about chemistry, I mean bond.
Is it Van der Waals?
The surface area
is enormous here.
The surface area of one mol--
we did this, right?
We looked at boiling points.
As you get a little longer,
a little longer, to C12.
This is C hundreds of thousands.
So the amount of bonding,
London dispersion, is enormous.
That's one of the reasons
these can be very strong.
But the tunability
is also enormous,
because I can just swap
in a different group
here, and polymerize that.
This is why this was so
exciting when it was--
polymers were first made
really in the '40s and '50s.
They really started coming
into the market in the '70s
en masse.
And now I want to tell
you why this matters.
We're going to start
with a commercial.
This is an ad on television
by Pepsi in 1978.
And I thought this
would be a nice way
to start my "Why This Matters."
It's only 30 seconds.
Uh-oh.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Pepsi Cola's new 2
liter plastic bottle.
It's tough.
Really tough.
And besides being touch,
Pepsi Cola's new 2 liter
plastic bottle is 25%
lighter than glass.
It's tough and light.
[END PLAYBACK]
Tough and light.
Now, apart from some other
potential differences
you may have noticed
with today's times, that
was the key.
That was one of the keys.
So they could make--
Pepsi and Coke,
Coca-Cola, could make
bottles that were lighter
than glass, but not break.
That was a very big deal.
And they really started--
in a lot of ways, they
started the revolution
of plastics and polymers
in commercial products.
Now, if you fast
forward to today,
I just want to show you
how bottles are made.
That's a 2 liter bottle.
Here is a 2 liter
bottle making plant.
And I think it's always
interesting to see how what
you're buying is actually made.
So here's just a
little short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Harden almost instantly thanks
to a built-in cooling system.
These preforms are
now on their way
to becoming single-serving
juice bottles.
This is another plastic
injection molding machine.
It uses the same
method to make preforms
for a different model, 1
and 1/2 to 2 liter bottles.
The preform's next stop is a
machine called a reheat stretch
blow molder.
In a matter of seconds, it
heats each preform just enough
to make the plastic
malleable, then inserts a rod
to stretch the
preform lengthwise,
while at the same time
blowing in air at extremely
high pressure.
This forces the preform
into a bottle-shaped mold.
Cold water circulates
within the mold to cool.
[END PLAYBACK]
So the reason I
wanted to show you
this is it just gives you a
sense of the pace, the pace.
Now, the pace is connected to
the material and the chemistry.
And it's things that
you already know.
When we did stress
strain curves,
one of the whole regions of it
is called plastic deformation.
These are plastics.
So one of the big
advantages of these things
is you can make like a small
mold like you do first,
and then that can be doled
out to different processes.
And in a matter of less than
a second with a little heat,
a little pressure, it can be
made into any bottle you want,
and then the next
one, and the next one.
Well, let's see.
We buy-- I'm going to write
a couple of things here--
let's see.
We buy as humans 1
million of those bottles,
plastic bottles--
anybody want to give me a unit?
Day.
It's per minute.
[GASPING]
We buy a million
globally per minute.
And the thing is, if you're
talking about plastic bottles,
91% of them are not recycled.
And so my "Why
This Matters," it's
going to turn a
little dark right now,
because the thing is, if you
compare with what nature does,
these are nature's polymers.
And I will talk about them
on Friday a little bit more.
And you can say, well,
nature's had millions
of years to work on this, sure.
Nature is the world's
greatest polymer engineer.
We are all polymers.
We are all polymers
of different types.
Amino acids, sugars,
cellulose, keratin.
Nature does this
in so many ways.
And of course, by definition,
these are biodegradable.
Now, that's what nature makes.
Here's what we make.
Now, this is a beach.
That's a coastline.
And there's a lot of places
where you can get some data.
I like Our World in Data.
You guys can take a look at
that and many other resources.
Here's a beach.
Here is a guy.
It's hard to see, but
he's actually in a boat.
That's a boat.
So that's all water.
And of course, there's
a lot of information
lately on things like
how much of this stuff
animals are eating.
And there's also
a lot of pictures
that are sometimes
difficult to see,
where animals get stuck in a
piece of plastic, for example.
And that can lead to death,
or deformity, as in this case.
And the thing is that we
have to think very carefully
about what we're doing.
And we have not done that
with regard to polymers.
We have not done that at all.
And just to give you a couple
more numbers, here's a chart.
This is how polymers
are used today.
Packaging is 40%.
40% of plastic produced
today is in packaging.
And the thing is--
sorry.
40% of the plastics
are used only once,
and then thrown away.
We all know that.
We drink a bottle of water out
of plastic, or all the way back
to the '70s, the Pepsi and the
Coke, and we throw it away.
But the thing is
that most of that,
a lot of that, most of that
winds up in the oceans.
And it takes about a half a
thousand years, 500 years,
to decompose.
So let's see.
A couple more numbers.
So first of all, only 7%
of all plastic is recycled.
Now, Coca-Cola and
Pepsi could use
a lot more recycled plastic.
One of the main reasons
they don't is the containers
wouldn't be see through.
And we can't have that, right?
As consumers, we've
got to see it.
It's got to be this
beautiful, clear container.
But as I said, most of
what's not recycled winds up
in the oceans.
And let's see, in 2050--
here's one.
In 2050, the
plastic in the ocean
will equal the
weight of all fish.
That includes whales and
large sea animals, everyone.
Now, the thing is that--
let's see.
Many of these plastics,
like polystyrene, there
is an example, they decompose.
And so when they're
large, large,
there is a chance
to collect them.
But the sunlight out in the
ocean, they float up to the top
or they get currents
that mix them,
and the sunlight, the UV energy
from the sun, decomposes them.
Eventually they get smaller
and smaller and smaller.
And eventually, they
get really tiny.
Those are called microplastics.
You say, well, why is that bad?
Because it's toxic,
for one thing.
Polystyrene is toxic.
The styrene molecule is toxic.
It's a carcinogen.
People who eat seafood
in some studies
are estimated to be eating
11,000 pieces of microplastic
a year.
That's what they're
ingesting today.
So this is the problem.
We're making these single-use
products, single-use, put it
in recycling because I'm a good
citizen, but 9 out of 10 times
it doesn't matter, because
it's not getting recycled.
Oh, and then it
goes in the ocean
where it stays for 500 years.
There's a plastic bottle.
There's fishing lines.
So this is the problem.
We should not be using things
on the minute timescale that
then take a half thousand
years to decompose
and are extremely
toxic when they do.
This is clearly a problem.
Now, there are a lot of
people working on this
and thinking about this.
Not enough.
And I want to tell
you about a book
that I read when it came
out a long time ago.
It's a wonderful book.
And I got reintroduced
to it last week.
By David McKay, who
unfortunately passed away
recently, but he wrote this
book called Sustainable Energy
Without the Hot Air.
And I highly recommend you
read this if you haven't.
It's free.
It's a free download.
WithoutHotAir.com.
Because he just goes through
sort of simply the math.
And the reason I'm bringing
this to your attention--
he doesn't really
talk about plastics.
He talks about energy--
is I love this
discussion in chapter 19.
Chapter 19 is titled
"Every BIG helps."
He says, if everyone
does a little,
we'll achieve only a little.
That is true.
We have this way of
talking about these crises
in little bits, because
it makes us feel better,
and it makes
companies feel better.
You talk about this with
the plastics in straws
has gotten a lot of press.
And companies kind
of do their part.
Although, Starbucks
is kind of funny,
because they replaced all
plastic straws with paper
straws encased in plastic.
That's actually more than the
plastic straws to begin with.
Single-use plastic again.
But anyway, they're trying.
They walk away.
They say, we tried.
No!
Because that's doing a little.
The plastic in the ocean
is 0.03% from straws.
There's so much
more we have to do.
We can't think little
about problems like this.
We can't.
We can't do that.
Now, there are
some big projects.
This is one that's
gotten some attention.
This is called Ocean Cleanup.
Now, they've gotten
a lot of attention.
They've got these rigs out
there that could collect some
of this plastic in the ocean.
And it's at least thinking big.
There's a lot of bold
claims that they're making.
A lot of bold claims,
a lot of hype.
But at least it's an
attempt to do something big.
One of the limitations
here though
is this technology can't
go below a centimeter.
It can't go below that.
It's not going to collect
below a centimeter.
But there are some
studies that estimate
that 90% of the
plastic in the ocean
already is below a
centimeter, and 60%,
70% of that has already sunk.
Talk about the need to think
about this in a big way.
This is a very big problem.
And I hope that
more and more people
get excited about
trying to tackle it
in big ways, not little ways.
That was my "Why This
Matters," nice and happy.
Nice and happy, why?
Because we're going to
solve these problems.
That's why.
We have to.
We have no choice.
I mentioned there were
two ways to make plastics
that I want to talk about.
I want to talk about
the second way now.
So the first way is called
radical polymerization,
because I take one
mer, and then I make it
into a really long chain.
The second way-- and that right
there is nylon, by the way.
Nylon can't be made that way.
And here's the reason.
Because in the second
way of making polymers,
we take two different
types of mers.
And this way is called
condensation polymerization.
It's a different way of
forming very, very long chains.
So on Wednesday,
we'll talk about what
you can do with
these chains, how
you can modify the properties,
kind like we do with glass.
We talked about the
fundamentals of glass,
and then we talked
about engineering it.
On Wednesday, we'll
talk about how
to engineer the properties
of these polymers.
But right now, I want to just
focus on how to make them.
And so in condensation
polymerization,
the goal is also to make
these super long strands,
but you do it with two
different starting molecules
and no initiator.
So how does that work?
Well, I'll take a--
I'll get to nylon in a sec.
But first, let's
just take something
called the dicarboxylic acid.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to leave a box inside.
And I'm going to say
that could be something.
That could be something.
But I know that on that
something, I've got this.
I've got a carbon, oxygen,
and hydrogen, and on this side
I've got the same thing.
OH.
So I've got the same
thing on both sides.
That's a dicarboxylic acid.
It's carboxylic acid.
Now, on this side, I'm
going to have another mer,
and it's going to be different.
And this one, I'm also
going to have a box.
And over here.
[SNEEZING]
Gesundheit.
I've got NH2.
And over here I've got NH2.
NH2.
Emphasizing the N is what's
connected to the box there.
That's why I drew it that way.
And that's called an amine.
This is an amine.
And this is called a diamine.
So this is a diamine
dicarboxylic acid.
And what happens is when those
two molecules-- so the box
can be anything.
The box can be whatever for now.
If it's got those ends
to it, if it's got
the carboxylic acid and amine--
so on the one hand,
the molecule's
got these groups on the
end, and on the other hand,
it's got these, then what
happens when I put them
in solution together?
Well, what happens is
these two pieces react.
These two pieces react.
And so what you get is--
let's see.
You've got C.
Here's my box there.
There's the O down there.
And let's see.
Now here's the
carbon on this side.
Oh, boy.
I'm going to run out of
room, and I don't want to.
So I'm going to move over here.
And recycle these boards so
that I can draw it nice and big.
So now what happens?
So these are reacting.
And so now what do I have?
So I have C, double bond O.
There's my carboxylic acid.
There's the box from
the left-hand molecule,
the one on the left there.
Here's another C, double bond O.
But look at what's happened.
I've formed a
carbon-nitrogen link.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
And then here's another box
that came from the amine.
And this is an NH.
And then there'd be
like another H there.
And there'd be another H--
yes, another OH here.
Yeah.
NH2.
So I got that back.
And what's happened?
What's happened is
I've made water.
I've made water, plus I've
connected these two molecules
together.
So if I want to be
complete about it,
I've got to add
a water molecule,
because that's what had
happened in the middle here.
The OH group saw the
H on the NH2 group,
and it said, hey, I
want to make water.
Can I do that?
And then the carbon
and the nitrogen
were like, you know what?
Let me check it out, internally.
Let me check out
my Lewis structure.
And it's like, yeah, you
can take the OH and the H
and make water, because then
we could connect and form
this bond here.
And that bond is
called an amide link.
That's that kind.
And so I've formed a kind
of bond between these two
molecules that's
a covalent bond.
And this polymer is a class
of polymers called polyamide.
Because you can
see now, OK, I've
given off some water,
condensation polarization,
but I'm also now ready.
I've got my carboxylic
acid, and my NH,
my amine groups there
ready to go again.
So if this side finds
another one of these,
it can attach and react.
And if this side finds
another one of those,
it can attach and react.
And it keeps going
and going and going.
In much the same way, it's
just now instead of a radical,
instead of initiating it
by tearing an electron out,
I simply have brought
together two types
of molecules that want
to, in giving up water,
react and form a bond.
That's very powerful.
It's very powerful,
because I can do--
I can now, like I said, this
can have whatever inside.
So now it's a different
way of thinking about it.
Before we had the mer.
And I could make the
mer whatever I want.
Just keep a double
bond somewhere,
and I can make a polymer.
That's a lot of flexibility.
Now, instead of
keeping a double bond,
just keep these amine and
carboxylic acid groups there,
and I can put anything
inside the boxes that I want.
Again, massive tunability.
And one of the funnest things
to do is the nylon rope pull.
We couldn't do it.
Apparently, it's a
little dangerous.
Nylon is when the box winds up
having a carbon chain in it.
Six carbon atoms.
And when this has
six carbon atoms
and this has six
carbon atoms, that's
called nylon 6,6, which
some of you may have seen.
So you get nylon 6,6, or
sometimes it's just called 66.
It's six carbon
atoms in the boxes.
You can imagine you
can make 6,8, 4,6.
You can play around.
You can put lots of
things in those boxes.
The nylon rope pull
is such a cool thing.
I had to show you a video.
Here's what you've got.
You've got one molecule
in solution on the top.
You can tell.
It's the slightly
lighter liquid.
And the other one on the bottom.
The amines on one side, these
carboxylic acid on the other.
This is nylon.
So the box is six carbon atoms.
Now, what's happening?
At the interface, this
reaction is occurring.
So what I can do,
and I'll play this.
Or what this person can do is
put a little piece of glass
stir in there and
pull nylon out.
So watch how he does this.
So you get it started.
There is a piece of solid
coming out of two liquids.
What's happening?
As he pulls it, more
is reacting and forming
more of these chains.
And you can just keep
going and going and going.
What's so cool
about this is you're
literally creating this
solid with functionality
that's tunable out of
these two liquid baths.
It's all happening
at the interface
where the two molecules, the
amine and the carboxylic acid
can see each other.
And there you can see it.
I wish you didn't have the
text there, but look at that.
You're pulling a polymer
right out of the interface
between two liquids.
That's how nylon is made.
And again, this had
an incredible impact
on so many applications.
I thought I'd show you this one.
That's the first
line in New York
to buy stockings,
nylon stockings.
And it's going on and on and on.
Of course, then there are a
few other applications, too,
like parachutes, and many, many,
many more, because again, it's
a whole other way
of making polymers.
Now, I'll talk more
about this on Wednesday.
But in your goody bag,
you've got old school fun.
And we'll talk about this in
the context of the things we're
going to learn more about
polymers and polymer
engineering.
See you guys on Wednesday.